Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden berichten.
Ich möchte ein paar Personen hier dachten, Herr Fragen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Klar, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ja, wir sind hier für Sie.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedrich Schneider.
Friedrich Schneider.
Können Sie bitte mir einen Namen lassen, bitte?
Ja, Friedrich Fr. I. E. D. R. I. C. H.
Und der Familienname Schneider, S. T. H. N. E. I. D. E. R.
Okay, Schneider.
Okay, Herr Schneider, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74.
Mhm.
Was ist die Genaubgebure?
Am 10.10. in 51.
Mhm.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie derzeit?
Ja, so 89 kg ungefähr.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m, die zumindest in meinem Ausweis haben.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was fühlt Sie heute so uns, Herr Schneider?
Ich habe solche heftigen Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein.
Das fing irgendwie ganz langsam an.
Eigentlich schon das ganze letzte Jahr hatte ich Probleme.
Das drückt und tut weh.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn ich mich ein bisschen angestrengt habe,
dann muss ich, wenn ich ein bisschen gelaufen bin,
ein paar Treppen oder auch nur so auf der Strecke zum Einkaufen,
ich konnte das früher völlig problemlos.
Und jetzt tut mir dann mit einmal das rechte Bein weh.
Und bisher waren die Schmerzen immer nur so im Unterschenkel.
Da habt ihr weh getan.
Aber vor drei Tagen fing es mit einmal an,
dass das im ganzen Bein richtig doll weh tut.
Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Angst zu kommen,
weil die Schmerzen wirklich auch immer schlimmer wurden.
Ich musste einfach stehen bleiben, ich konnte nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Das ging einfach nicht.
Früher war das so, dass ich ein ganzes Stück laufen konnte.
Also ja, das, was ich bis zu meinem Einkaufsladen,
das habe ich immer noch gut geschafft.
Dann musste ich da zwar ein wenig stehen bleiben
und dann konnte ich aber auch nachher wieder zurückgehen.
Aber jetzt seit ein paar Tagen, da komme ich nicht mal
bis vor auf die Straße runter, da tut schon das Bein so doll weh.
Okay.
Okay, habe ihr richtig verstanden, Herr Schneider.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie starke Schmerzen
im rechten Unterschenkel?
Ja, im ganzen Bein jetzt.
Früher war es immer nur im Unterschenkel
und seit drei Tagen ist es im ganzen Bein.
Jetzt kann ich, also habe ich das Gefühl,
ich kann eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr laufen.
Okay, ganzem Bein.
Und die Schmerzen sind am nächsten Jahr angefangen.
Bitte was?
Die Schmerzen sind am nächsten Jahr, seit nächsten Jahr angefangen.
Ja, da hat es so langsam angefangen,
dass ich nicht mehr so unbeschränkt laufen konnte.
Dann tat es nach einer Weile, wenn ich ein bisschen länger gelaufen bin,
tat es mit einmal im Unterschenkel weh.
Okay.
Okay, schüttert dann die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Ja, Sie haben schon erwähnt, da sich Schmerzen,
dann ganzem Bein.
Ja, also, wie?
Ja, das war es im Unterschenkel.
Und jetzt ist es wirklich im ganzen Bein,
so dass ich das Begrünen habe,
ich kann gar nicht mehr auf.
Aber es strahlt dann nicht irgendwie noch weiter aus.
Okay.
Ja, wie schüttert sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala
von eins bis zehn, Herr Schneider?
Was ist eins und was ist zehn?
Ja, eins ist sehr leichte Schmerz.
Sehen Sie das Schmerz?
Ja, also sehr leicht sind die Schmerzen wirklich nicht.
Also vielleicht so bei sieben oder so würde ich sagen.
Über die Hälfte jedenfalls.
Ich kann ja mit einmal überhaupt nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Okay.
Ja, können Sie diese Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Aufnahmegespritz aushalten?
Ja, jetzt muss ich eigentlich laufen.
Jetzt tut es nicht so wie wenn ich in Ruhe bin, tut es ja nicht weh.
Ja, genau.
Okay, möchten Sie Schmerzenteil einnehmen?
Nein, ich habe gesagt, jetzt habe ich ja keine Schmerzen.
Jetzt muss ich ja nicht laufen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie laufen, haben Sie starke Schmerzen.
Genau.
Und der Weg den ich schaffen kann wird immer kürzer, ne?
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plöstig angefangen, aufgezwitten?
Das ging langsam los, ja.
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, naja gut, hast du dich falsch bewegt
oder ein bisschen über anstrengend, aber dann wurde das halt immer mehr.
Also wirklich langsam angefangen und immer mehr geworden.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen ein Auslöser für diese Schmerzen aufgefallen?
Ja, wenn ich laufe, dann tut es weh.
Okay, laufen.
Okay.
Waren Sie schon beim Arzt?
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden schon beim Arzt?
Nein, mein Hausarzt hat Urlaub.
Und weil das jetzt mit einmal so heftig geworden ist
und ich gar nicht mehr laufen kann, bin ich jetzt hier direkt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, das ist eine großartige Entscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten oder Herzrasen, Herzstöpeln?
Nein, also ich hatte vor Jahren hatte ich mal ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Herzen,
aber schon lange her.
Und da habe ich seinerzeit ein Stand ins Herz bekommen, aber seit ich den habe,
komme ich eigentlich gut klar.
Okay, haben Sie Atemnot, besonders bei Belastung, beim Laufen?
Nein, also die Atemnot, die macht es nicht, die Schmerzen sind nur da.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwellung, Rötung oder Überwärmung an den Beinen?
Also eigentlich ist mir das nicht aufgefallen.
Also eher ist das rechte Bein so ein bisschen kühl.
An den Beinen besonders.
Ja, also das rechte Bein ist nicht geschwollen oder so.
Ich würde sagen, es ist eher ein bisschen kühler als das andere.
Okay.
Und es fühlt sich auch so ein bisschen, ich habe manchmal so ein Kribbeln da in den Beinen.
Wie eingeschlafen die Füße halt.
Okay, haben Sie Taubheizgefühl oder Lehmung?
Ja, so ein bisschen Taubheizgefühl kann man schon sagen.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, haben Sie morgens Bewegung, Einschränkung oder Stabilkeit?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Okay, können Sie oder wie viele Meter können Sie Onicht, Merzen gehen?
Ja, früher konnte ich mit meinem Hund Kilometer langspazieren gehen, aber jetzt...
5 Kilometer.
Nein, also 5 vielleicht nicht, aber 2 oder 3.
Aber jetzt kann ich, also noch gerade wie gesagt bis zu meiner, bis zu Haustür oder so, das sind vielleicht 100 Meter.
Ja, und dann muss ich schon wieder stehen bleiben.
Ja, können Sie noch mal sagen, wie viele Meter?
100 Meter.
Vielen Dank.
Okay, haben Sie oder sind die Beine...
Nein, ist das Bein dicker als andere Bein geworden?
Das haben Sie gerade schon gefragt, nein, ist es nicht.
Also ist mir zumindest nicht aufgefallen, die Schuhe passen genauso, die Socken passen genauso, ja.
Ja, okay.
Okay, habe abgesehen von Ihren Bescheiden, haben Sie Fibre, Schüttefrost oder Nachweiss?
Nein, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Also ich schlafe nachts ganz schlecht, weil ich auch oft auf die Toilette gehen muss, ja.
Und jetzt ist es auch so, dass manchmal nachts das Bein dann auch...
Also wenn ich dann aufwache, dann merke ich, dass es weh tut.
Und dann wird es eigentlich erst besser in dem Augenblick, wo ich mich auf die Bettkante setze und einen kleinen Augenblick warte.
Und dann kann ich auch eben auf die Toilette gehen, ne?
Okay, wie viele Mal müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja, so zweimal eigentlich schon jede Nacht, ja.
Zweimal jede Nacht, okay.
Okay, haben Sie in der Südzeit ab oder zu gehen, oder?
Nein, also ich glaube nicht. Ich habe mich jetzt nicht heute Morgen gewogen oder so, aber denke mal, das ist alles noch genauso wie vorher.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Schüttergang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich gerade gesagt, dass ich nachts oft raus muss, ja.
Und beim Stuhlgang kommt eigentlich... Nee, das läuft ganz vernünftig, ja.
Okay, Herr Schneider.
Sind bei Ihnen bestimmt die chronische Alkrankungen bekannt?
Ich meine, Blutzuckerkrankheit, Blutotel...
Ja, in meinem Alter, wissen Sie, da haben das doch alle Jahre, zehn Jahre, habe ich diesen Alterszucker.
Und da nehme ich regelmäßig mit Formientabletten und meinen Hausarzt untersucht das auch immer mal wieder.
Und natürlich habe ich auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Aber das ist ja bei allen Leuten eigentlich so.
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen.
Ja, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie Blutotel haben. Seit wann haben Sie diese Alkrankung?
Mit dem Blutdruck? Ach, das fing schon vor 20 Jahren an.
Ja, 20 Jahre, okay.
Haben Sie sonstige chronische Alkrankungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte diese Herzgeschichte da, wo ich den Stunt bekommen habe.
Das ist so, ja, ist jetzt 15 Jahre her.
15.
Aber seit her habe ich dann jetzt schon schon schon keine Beschwerden mehr.
Seit vor 15 Jahren hatten Sie Herzschwittern, oder?
Ja, also da hatte ich halt so Herzprobleme und da haben die in Stunt gesetzt.
Okay, vor 15 Jahren.
Vor 15 Jahren, hm?
Okay.
Und also, weil ich da jetzt eben diesen Stand habe,
nehme ich regelmäßig aus Pirin ein 100 morgens.
Okay, 100 morgens.
Okay, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie mit Formin einnehmen.
Hm?
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
Das sind 800, dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay, die weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Hatten Sie, oder, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, okay, haben Sie schon erwähnt, dass Sie vor 15 Jahren...
Ja, diesen Stand da, ne?
Ja, ich habe das Erkrankungen gestanden, haten, aber sonstige.
Also muss ich mal nachgehen, oder?
Ja, ich habe das nicht mehr nachdenken.
Als Kind habe ich, glaube ich, mal die Mandeln rausgekommen.
Ja, aber irgendwie so, das ist ja schon so lange her,
dass ja schon fast nicht mehr war.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Schneider,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente außer mit Formin und Aspirin ein?
Ja, ich nehme noch Simvastatin ein.
Ich nehme noch dieросischen, nicht gegen den Blutdruck.
Mhm.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
Das steht, glaube ich, 20 drauf und dann nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Abends.
Einmal täglich.
Okay.
Sind Sie prostandige, Herr Schneider?
Ja, also, jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Ja, die Grippeimpfung lasse ich immer machen, so was alte Leute halt machen sollen.
Und ich habe mich auch dieses Jahr noch mal gegen Corona empfangen lassen, ja.
Das sollen alte Leute ja machen.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Okay, ganz genau.
Haben Sie bekannte Allergin oder Untertechnikkeiten?
Herr Schneider.
Eigentlich kann ich alles essen und trinken.
Ja, super.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas gibt, was mir nicht bekommt.
Okay.
Okay, rauchen Sie, Herr Schneider?
Nicht mehr, nicht mehr.
Also viele Jahre lang habe ich geraucht, aber nicht so reschrecklich viel.
Also immer nur so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag, das hielt sich sehr in Grenzen.
Aber das habe ich jetzt so vor 15 Jahren, so etwas.
Ja, als es mit dem Herzen war, da habe ich das aufgehört mit dem rauchen.
Okay, ja super. Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ach ja, eigentlich mein ganzes erwachsenen Leben, also 40 Jahre, können Sie sagen.
Entschuldigung. Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Schneider?
Ja, also jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr, so viel früher.
Ich habe als Gastwirt gearbeitet, da musste man natürlich an der Theke manchmal was mit trinken.
Und ja, da hat man schon mal ziemlich viel Bier getrunken oder so.
Aber jetzt eigentlich seit ich in Rente bin, habe ich eigentlich...
Gelegenste, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, also kann man sagen, wenn ich mal meine Freunde treffe oder so.
Oder wenn ich mal mit jemandem essen gehe, aber eigentlich sehr selten.
Okay, hatten Sie früher...
Hatten Sie früher wie viel Flasche hatten Sie früher getrunken?
Das waren vielleicht so drei, vier Bier am Abend oder auch mal Schnaps dabei.
Ja, nehmen Sie bitte nicht, das ist eine Routinefrage, Herr Schneider.
Haben Sie jemals Drogen konsumiert?
Drogen? Also außer Alkohol habe ich keine Drogen konsumiert, nein.
Okay.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich weiß, momentan treiben Sie nicht Sport machen, aber
früher.
Ja, also so richtig sportlich war ich ehrlich gesagt nie.
Aber wissen Sie, ich habe einen Hund, mit dem muss ich ja regelmäßig rausgehen.
Und das hat mich eigentlich immer ganz gut in Bewegung gehalten.
Okay.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, ich habe schon lange keine Urlaubsweise mehr gemacht.
Okay.
Sind Sie in Ihrer Familie bestimmt der krönliche Alkoholkungen bekannt?
Ja, also mein Vater, der ist ganz früh gestorben, der hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Und meine Mutter, ja, die ist zwar ein bisschen älter geworden als mein Vater,
aber die hatte irgendwas so, dass sie eine Lungenembolie hatte.
Und daran ist sie letztendlich gestorben.
Es tut mir leid, Herr Schneider.
Aber es ist natürlich schon schrecklich lange her, ich bin ja schon selber in dem Alter, wie die gestorben ist.
Genau.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Schneider?
Sie haben schon Erwandt, aber ja, akustisch habe ich nicht gehört.
Jetzt tut mir leid.
Also jetzt bin ich natürlich im Ruhestand.
Aber ich hatte eine Kneipe, eine Gastwirtschaft.
Und vor allen Dingen so Abendbetrieb, wo viel getrunken wurde.
Und natürlich auch früher viel geraucht.
Ja, seit ein paar Jahren darf man das ja nicht mehr.
Aber doch, bei uns in der Kneipe wurde noch heftig geraucht.
Und ja, auch war schon auch eine anstrengende Zeit den ganzen Abend auf den Beinen.
Ja, natürlich.
Wegen der Arbeit, wahrscheinlich haben Sie so viel getrunken.
Ja, beide Arbeit.
Dann haben die Leute gesagt, ja, komm, trink einen mit.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Oh, ich bin alleine.
Meine Frau ist vor ein paar Jahren gestorben.
Und Kinder hatten wir nie.
Und ja, dadurch bin ich jetzt wirklich ganz alleine.
Ich habe nur noch mein Hund, ja.
Okay.
Es tut mir leid für Ihre Frau.
Okay, damit sind wir mit den Fragen durch.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will natürlich gerne wissen, was mit meinen Beinen da ist.
Warum das so wehtut und natürlich auch, was man dagegen machen kann.
Ich will ja wieder mit meinem Hund rausgehen.
Der braucht mich ja.
Ja, ja, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen, Herr Schneider.
Aber ja, momentan kann ich noch nichts, die Herr sagen,
die ist sehr gut und sich aber auch sehr gut unterhalten.
Ich möchte genau das.
Sonst lassen wir einen Röntgen bilden.
Einen Ultraschall.
Ultraschall.
Ja, okay.
Tut das weh?
Nein, das ist Schimmerslos unterhalten.
Ein Schmerzlose untersuchen. Na ja gut, dann soll es mal so sein.
Wenn wir Ihre Ergebnisse haben, können wir die weiteren Schritte besprechen.
Das klingt gut, ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte einen Platz im Martezimmer.
Okay, danke schön. Dann setz dich mich jetzt rüber.
Okay.
Möchte ich jemand noch irgendwas anderes zusätzliches fragen?
Sie haben erschöpfend gefragt, offensichtlich, ja.
Kommt keine weiteren Nachfragen.
Brauchen Sie ein paar Minuten zum bisschen notieren und nachdenken?
Ja, machen Sie mal in Ruhe.
Okay, mach Sie mal zwei oder drei Minuten.
Ja, ja, machen Sie in Ruhe.
Und dann melden Sie sich, wenn es weitergehen kann, ja?
Danke.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich habe eine Frage.
Oh ja, gerne.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe kalte Früße und Beine.
Und haben Sie schlechte Heilende Wunden?
Ne, ne Wunde habe ich nicht am Bein. Zum Glück nicht, nee.
Okay.
Kann losgehen?
Okay, ich würde mich bitten.
Bitte?
Ich könnte anfangen.
Sehr gut, wunderbar, ja.
Okay, ich...
Ich muss meine Sätze...
Okay, guten Tag.
Gut, dass ich Sie treffe.
Heute möchte ich einen neuen Passiaten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Aber ja, natürlich, den haben Sie schon gesehen.
Okay.
Ja, das war es.
Was für eine Sage, die ich in diesem Passiaten hatte.
Ja, ich hatte die Sage.
Ich hatte noch ein paar Sagen, die ich geredet habe,
und dann habe ich einen kleinen Passiaten.
Und dann habe ich eine andere Sage.
Ich habe eine andere Sage.
Das war es.
Und dann habe ich eine andere Sage.
Hier haben sie 7 von 10 auf der Skala gewartet.
Ist das ein dauerhaftes Schmerz?
Dauerhaftes Schmerz, genau.
Okay.
Schmerz sind dauerhaft.
Genau, dauerhaft.
Und...
Gibt es da Ausspröse?
Das sind die Ausspröse, die die
kalt ist das ist ein kaltes Gefühl.
Eine kaltes Gefühl.
Und...
Die vegetative Anamnesis ist unheimlich.
Bis auf Schmerz und Nitri bedingt für Tomi.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren eine Operation wegen der Herzerkrankung.
Und es wurde bei ihm mit Schitanzbehandlung durchgeführt.
Ernimmt regelmäßig Aspirin 100 mg morgens mit 28 mg zweimal täglich Simastatin 20 mg abends ein.
Er sei nicht rauf. Vor 15 Jahren hat er mit dem Rauf aufgehört.
Er ist 40 Jahre alt und hat nur 40 Zigaretten geraucht.
Er hat 3-4 Jahre lang abends abends getrunken.
Er hat eine
Urduk-Konsum.
Er ist unabhängig.
Er hat seinen Mutabes auf einer Mio-Kart-Impfakt gestorben.
Sie haben einen langen Emboli gestorben.
Und sie haben einen Kind.
Momentan sind sie auch Rente.
Sie haben eine Gastwirtschaft gearbeitet.
Eine Gastwirtschaft, okay.
Und er ist Elain.
Elain steht.
Für ein paar Jahre,
hat seine Frau gestorben.
Okay, fertig.
Was ist denn Ihre Vermutung?
Angaben deuten am ehesten auf.
Periferia arteria ferschlusskrankheit.
Ja.
Oder was könnte es alternativ unter Umständen noch sein?
Unter Umständen, ähm, als Differenzial Diagnosen kommen.
Ähm, Tiefevenentrombose.
Ja.
Äh, Erisupal.
Achso, okay, ja.
Und, ähm, Diskusprolaps.
Sehr gut, ja, sehr gut, okay.
Ja.
Im Bechtrags.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch, um rauszufinden, was mit den Patienten tatsächlich ist?
Ja, äh, zur weiteren Abklärung, ähm, zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich, äh, bei, würde ich, äh, die, ähm,
bei den Patienten, äh, stationärsch, äh, nein, äh, ambulant aufnehmen.
Mhm.
Äh, ambulant aufnehmen, äh, und äh, äh, ah, ein Moment, ja, es tut mir leid.
Soweit, dann Abklärung würde ich bei, äh, bei den Patienten, äh, digital Parameter überwachen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja, was machen Sie noch?
Äh, und die, äh, Körperlieruntersuchung dürführen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie denn besonders bei der Körperlichenuntersuchung?
Okay, ja, äh, bei der Körperlieruntersuchung, äh, äh, kontrolliere ich Puls.
Welchen Puls?
Äh, tibialis posterior, dorsalis pedis, äh, anders, äh, betroffnen Bein, besonders.
Äh, und, aber nicht nur, ne?
Ja, ja, nicht nur.
Ja, also im Seitenvergleich, das ist ja wichtig, ne?
Ja, beides.
Und, Bruttdruck, äh, und, äh, Sauerstoffsetigung.
Okay, ja.
Von der, von allein von der Optik, wonach gucken Sie?
Äh, äh, äh, äh, vielleicht so ein kleiner Tipp, der Patient hat gesagt, sein Bein ist kälter.
Ah, äh, genau, neurologische Untersuchung, äh, ich würde neurologische Untersuchung tun, ja.
Aber, was machen Sie mit Ihren Augen?
Genau, äh, ja, äh, ich kontrolliere Hautfarbeveränderung.
Ja, genau, ob das Bein blasser ist als das andere, ne?
Oder vielleicht sogar blau verfärbt oder was auch immer, ja.
Ja, ja, mhm.
Hautfarbeveränderung und ähm, ja, was könnte denn das Bein,
ja, was könnte denn noch sein, nicht nur, dass die Hautfarbe verändert ist, mhm,
sondern, was könnte noch sein?
Ja, sondern auch, äh, ja, ich habe schon gesagt, neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Ja, aber ähm, die Haut könnte ja auch noch, ähm, in sofern auffällig sein,
dass er z.B. eine Schuppe gehaut hat oder äh, praktisch Haarverlust, ne,
dass die Beinhaare ausgefallen sind.
Haaraus, ja.
Oder auch, dass die, dass die Fußnägel nicht mehr äh, komplett sind, mhm.
Ja, ich konnt, ich konnt's, ich konnt's für alle alles, genau.
Hautfarbeveränderung, alopeci, mhm.
Äh, and am Bein, and am,
Ja, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie noch?
Die Labor-Unter-Suchung ist sinnvoll, um falsche Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Was lassen Sie denn alles bestimmen?
Ich würde ein kleines Blut mit CRPBSG, Nebos, Nierenmalte und Hemoktobina 1C.
Ah, weil der Diabetiker ist, ja.
Der Diabetiker ist der Trombose.
Und Gelindubsparameter?
Auch, ja.
Weil er aus Berien nimmt, ja, okay.
Und Elektrolytum bestimmen, was?
Was machen Sie sonst weiter für Untersuchungen?
Oder veranlassen Sie?
Ja, ich würde gerne Dopplerzono-Grafie,
Durführe, Dopplerzono-Grafie.
Und bei der Zono-Grafie kontrolliere ich Beinverschluss in der Bein-Bluetfer.
Also in den Beinarterien, ne?
Ja, Beinarterienverschluss dient.
Ja, ob da was verschlossen ist, genau, ja.
Und Gegebungfallsveranlasste ich Angiografie?
Sehr gut, ja.
Sehr gut, okay.
Gut, ja.
Ja, dann bin ich mal gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen herauskommt,
ob der tatsächlich eine BRVK hat.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden, wie Ihre Ergebnisse sind
und dann müssen wir langfristig überlegen, wie wir mit den Patienten weiterverfahren.
Wenn der jetzt akut sich so verschlechtert hat,
müssen wir gucken, ob wir jetzt sofort irgendwas intervenieren müssen, ne?
Gut, ich darf das nur draufnehmen.
Dann, ja.
Gut, wunderbar.
Ja, Sie haben Sie doch gut geschlagen fürs erste Mal, kann man mal so sagen.
Sie haben eigentlich eine schöne komplette Darstellung jetzt gebracht
und bei Ihrer Befragung des Patienten, da habe ich eigentlich gar nicht viel zu schimpfen.
Da habe ich eigentlich nur eine Sache,
dass Sie immer wieder haben Sie gefragt haben, ne?
Manchmal haben Sie sich so ein bisschen, hat man gemerkt,
woher haben Sie anfangen, oder ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Aber nochmal ein paar andere Formulierungen wäre ganz schön.
Dann haben Sie manchmal nicht so richtig auf die Sachen reagiert,
die er Ihnen schon erzählt hat.
Sie hatten Ihren Fragenkatalog
und wenn der vorher schon gesagt hat, das Problem habe ich,
dann haben Sie das nochmal nachgefragt
und da hat er ja auch so ein bisschen unwirsch reagiert,
habe ich Ihnen doch gerade schon gesagt, ne?
Haben Sie gemerkt, ja?
Ja.
Und, ja, was ich sehr schön fand in der Präsentation nachher,
dass Sie gesagt haben oder beschrieben haben,
diese Claudicatio Intermittens,
das ist natürlich genau der richtige Fachbegriff, ja.
Und, was mir nicht so gut gefallen hat,
dass Sie gesagt haben, die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft,
sondern das ist ja genau die Geschichte,
dass die nicht dauerhaft sind.
Ja, die Leute stehen bleiben.
Genau, ja.
Können die ja eigentlich in Augenblick verschnaufen
und dann geht es wieder mit den Schmerzen.
Ja, beim Laufen besonders.
Ja, und eben bei Belastung
und das Einzige, was so ein bisschen kritisch ist jetzt bei dem,
das er erzählt hat, auch, ja, wenn der Nacht so aufwacht,
dann merkt er, dass das bei ein Weh tut.
Da haben wir ja schon fast ein Ruheschmerz, ja.
Aber genau genommen ist er noch in dieser Phase, wo er...
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ja, wo er...
Ich habe fast gesagt.
Wo er noch eben die Schmerzen durchdurchdreht hat.
Und da haben sie eigentlich nicht so konsequent in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch
drauf hingewiesen, wie lange das schon so ist.
Dass der also praktisch schon ein Jahr lang merkt,
dass es schlechter wird.
Ja, aber das eben immer noch kompensiert hat.
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch so,
das typische Mann hat irgendwelche Beschwerden
und denkt, dass er in der Phase,
wenn er in der Phase, wenn er in der Phase,
irgendwelche Beschwerden und denkt,
wieso tuten das jetzt weh?
Und dann merkt man, ja, irgendwie wird nicht so richtig besser.
Aber na gut, wenn ich stehenbleibe,
kann ich es ja aushalten.
Also geht man erst mal noch nicht zum Arzt.
Man geht erst zum Arzt, wenn es wirklich schlimm wird, ne?
Gut.
Ja, was Sie schön gemacht haben,
die Sie Vorerkrankungen erwähnt haben,
dass ich in der Präsentation, also im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
ein bisschen auffällig fand,
Sie haben sehr, sehr oft und gesagt,
und sein Vater ist gestorben an,
was habe ich gesagt,
der Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt, genau.
Also und sein Vater ist am Herzinfarkt gestorben
und seine Mutter mit 75.
Und er ist Einzelkind, ja,
und bislang hatte er das und das gemacht.
Also, dass Sie da vielleicht auch einfach nur einen Fassagen punkt,
und dann fängt ein neuer Satz an.
Und manchmal ist es schon ganz nett,
wenn man so ein bisschen die Überleitung macht,
wenn man Familien an einem Nestig gab, der Patient,
und er hat dann auch einen Schatz an,
das ist sein Vater.
Also eine kleine Überleitung,
ja, oder auch, auch,
was seine berufliche Tätigkeit angeht.
Der Patient ist jetzt im Ruhestand,
er lebt alleine, er ist verwitwit
und hat keine Kinder
und er hat ja immer wieder davon angefangen,
dass er sein Hund hat, ja.
Und der Hund ist also seine Bezugsperson für diesen Mann, ja.
Der ist ihm ganz wichtig
und deswegen ist er der einzige Grund,
weshalb er wieder laufen will, ja,
weil er mit seinem Hund rausgehen muss.
Ja, sonst wäre das alles egal, ja.
Und insofern ist es, glaube ich,
schon auch ne Erwähnung wert,
dass der eben auch noch ein Tier zu versorgen hat.
Er kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen,
tschüss, Leute, ich gehe jetzt ins Krankenhaus,
sondern man muss ja für den irgendwie auch sich kümmern,
dass er eben versorgt ist, ne.
Gut, ja, was eigentlich sehr schlussig schön war,
war ihre Vorschläge zur Untersuchung.
Wichtig eben, genau,
Fußpulse im Seitenfang gleich
und in der Optik gucken,
ob es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen den beiden Beinen
und natürlich auch,
das war eine Frage, die ja hier noch kam,
ob der Patient wund hat an den Beinen.
Natürlich muss man auch sehr genau die Füße angucken,
ob der da irgendwelche wunden Stellen hat,
ob da möglicherweise was ist.
Sind sie fit in der,
in der Grad-Einstufung,
in Stadion der PRVK?
Wie sind die Stadien definiert?
Das ist, ja, die Therapie hängt von Stadium ab
und der Patient steht im Stadium 2B.
Dieser Patient ist im Stadium 2B.
Was wäre der Stadium 3?
Stadium 3, weniger als 50 Meter
und dauerhaft die Geschmerzen.
Geschmerzen, genau, ja, sehr gut.
Und was ist dann Stadium 4?
Stadium 4, Geschmerzen.
Ah, ok, Necrotische im Hunden.
Ja, sehr gut, ja gut.
Also sie bleiben nix schuldig, ja, alles klar.
Gut, ich würde mal...
Frau Wichmann?
Hallo.
Ich bin auch hier, aber...
Frau Wichmann ist weg.
Wahrscheinlich.
Andere hören sie uns?
Ja, genau, wie alle hier.
Ja, klar.
Merhaba, herkese.
Merhaba.
Frau Wichmann.
Nein, Mikrofon, Mikrofon.
Jetzt, ja, super.
Sind sie alle rausgeflogen oder bin nur ich rausgeflogen?
Nur sie.
Verrückt, von einer Sekunde auf die andere war es los, ja.
Gut, dabei wollte ich gerade sagen,
was Sie für eine schöne Veranstaltung geboten haben.
Sie haben das wunderbar gemacht.
Ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten habe ich mit der Verständlichkeit ihrer Sprache.
Also der Akzent ist schon auch relativ stark,
obwohl sie grammatikalisch sehr richtig sprechen.
Aber das ist so ein Problem,
das ich schon mal mit der Kollegin besprochen habe.
Versuchen Sie, die Stimme weiter nach vorne zu bringen.
Dass sie nicht zu hinten im Hals sprechen,
sondern dass sie weiter vorne sprechen.
Dann ist es ein bisschen leichter zu verstehen.
Das ist natürlich sehr schwer, sich da umzustellen.
Aber grundlegend schwierig, sie zu verstehen, war das nicht.
Aber ich bin wirklich begeistert.
Wir sagen sehr, machen das das erste Mal.
Dafür ist es wirklich richtig super gewesen.
Und ich glaube, Sie müssen vor Ihrer Prüfung keine Angst haben.
Das war sozusagen unser Weihnachtsschwanker.
Ich würde mich jetzt verabschieden von Ihnen allen.
Für dieses Jahr.
Wir treffen uns dann.